die Produkte die er hier vor mir seht
kosten im Durchschnitt 10 € wir haben
ein Risotto Rouladen eine Hummersuppe
Honig Spaghetti Carbonara Müsli oder
auch Popcorn ein steht fest alle sind
teuer aber wir stellen uns heute die
Frage sind Sie es auch wert wie z.B
unser 10 € alten Blütenhonig ich bin
euch ganz ehrlich ich habe euch noch nie
so teuren Honig gegessen und ich bin
gespannt ob er es wert ist 10 € Alben
bieten Honig in der bestmöglichen Form
butterkörnerbrötchen Attacke
schmeckst du die Blüten aus den Alpen ja
ja schmeckt übrigens geil der schmeckt
übelst geil richtig süß richtig lecker
schmeckt definitiv nicht so wie dieser
Quatsch Honig der schmeckt so bisschen
wie Zuckerwasser das hier ist schon echt
gut aber 10 € wir bewerten immer mein
Geschmack und den Preis Leistung
geschmacklich 9,5 von 10 Preis Leistung
5 von 10 falls ihr euch fragt wo wir das
alles her haben wir waren extra in
Düsseldorf in einem Luxus Supermarkt und
haben die teuersten der teuren Produkte
gefunden Preise angeschaut Produkte
verglichen und viel Spaß mit dem
weiteren Video was könnte man machen
Honig für 10 € Essen richtig ein Müsli
für 10 €, also ich finde bei Honig
konnte man es noch mehr verstehen aber
was macht ein Müsli 10 € teuer gucken
wir mal auf die Zutatenliste wir haben
Vollkorn Haferflocken Mandeln 10,7%
Sonnenblumenöl und Zimt auch alles
relativ eingängige Zutaten wo ich jetzt
nicht wüsste warum es so ultra teuer
Müsli oder so der Geschmack wird es
hoffentlich rechtfertigen machen wir
einmal auf ich finde gebrannte Mandeln
so eine Müsli hat man jetzt auch noch
nicht gesehen das ist schon geil ist
auch eine extra Schritt so in der
Produktion erstmal gebannte Mandeln
machen
sehr leckeres Müsli ne erst die Milch
oder erst das Müsli ich glaube es gibt
nur eine richtige Antwort erst das Müsli
das sieht halt gut aus alter was soll
ich dir sagen aber gefühlt ist das jetzt
halb leer Milch drauf wie schmeckt 10 €
Müsli
schmeckst du den 10 € Schein
ist auf jeden Fall leckeres Müsli ne
keine Frage wir haben so ein bisschen
Zimt dabei wir haben die gebrannten
Mandeln wir haben keine über krasse süße
also es ist schon so ein ausbalanciertes
Produkt aber ich muss ehrlich sagen wenn
wir jetzt jemand gesagt hat er die Tüte
kostet 3 € hätte aber super günstig oder
hätte ich nicht gedacht das ist so
Premium oder so kann sein dass diese
Quantic Queen halt einfach nur eine sehr
kleine Brand ist man sieht auch oben
drauf die Instagram handelt deine
crunchy Queen Julia also liebe Grüße an
Julia dein Produkt wirklich sehr lecker
wer weiß vielleicht ist das Produkt auch
so teuer weil der Lebensmittel
Einzelhandel sich so viel davon
wegnehmen und sie sonst ihre Kosten
nicht dran kann das wird seinen guten
Grund haben
also 10 €, ist mir einfach zu teuer
Geschmack acht von zehn Preis Leistung 3
von 10 lecker ist es aber verdammt teuer
das hier ist das teuerste Produkt dass
wir heute haben eine Hummersuppe für
sage und schreibe 18 € aus der Dose
alter Schwede dafür muss auf jeden Fall
echt darüber drin sein wir gucken auf
die Zutatenliste Nummer eins
das heißt mit anderen Worten die Panzer
der Hummer die natürlich ordentlich
Geschmack noch abgeben Butter Sahne
Cognac Cognac Tom mag Zwiebeln kräuter
Gewürze mit Hummer und Cognac haben wir
zwei sehr teure Zutaten die auf jeden
Fall einen höheren Preis rechtfertigen
designtechnisch ist es für mich schon
mal eine 10 von 10 aber darum geht's
heute nicht sieht schon mal nicht so
übelst geil aus nee wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen zweiphasig und unten ist die
Flüssigkeit die ist
Zubereitung ist denkbar einfach
eigentlich während man es nur auf hier
steht aber drauf wenn man das beste
Ergebnis will muss man sie noch mal
aufschäumen erstmal machen schön
schaumig geworden dafür muss man jetzt
auch wirklich nichts können außer diesen
Stab halten und dann kriegt ein bisschen
dreckig machen und jetzt gucken wir mal
wie viele Teller wir daraus ziehen
könnten wenn das so eine klassische
Vorspeise ist also vier Vorspeisen
Teller kriegt man da auf jeden Fall raus
mehr auch nicht in diesem Szenario muss
ich sagen während 450 eigentlich okay
weil man ist halt nicht jeden Tag eine
Hummer Creme Suppe ne das muss man
fairerweise sagen ist etwas anderes als
das Müsli zum Beispiel deshalb finde ich
auch wegen der rohzutat Hunger den
höheren Preis hat muss man hier ein
bisschen anders herangehen guckt euch
das mal an die geht wirklich die ist
sehr sehr sehr
cremig die zweite Zutat auf der
Zutatenliste ist Butter so wie es halt
häufig in der Spitzengastronomie ist
und die riecht wirklich sehr sehr gut
probieren wir
wenn ich die so auch so aufgewärmt aus
der Dose in einem spitzen Restaurant
serviert bekommen würde ich würde glaube
ich keinen Moment mich fragen ob das
irgendwie ein Fertiggericht ist oder so
ich habe ein bisschen mehr erwartet also
mehr hungergeschmack erwartet bei dem
hohen Preis weil mehr Hunger Geschmack
heißt für mich auch irgendwie da ist
mehr Hunger drin ich finde Todes lecker
aber unnormal lecker geschmacklich würde
ich dir Suppe einen neuen von 10 geben
keine zehn von zehn weil es noch krasser
nach Hunger schmecken würde mit der
gleichen Charakteristik mit der Würze
mit der Vollmundigkeit dann wäre 10
preis Leistung ist eigentlich auch schon
wieder eine 5 von 10 für mich was sagst
du 7% gesagt sechs von zehn sechs zehn
oh Gott
kleiner Zwischengang bevor wir gleich zu
den Spaghetti Carbonara kommen Popcorn
Popcorn aus dem Pott das ist zwar nicht
der sloggen aber es würde sehr gut
passen das beste
Pop aus Deutschland oder das beste Pop
meines Lebens denn das sollte es sein
das kostet nämlich 5, 50 für sage und
schreibe 150 Gramm das ist krank
Geschmack Gin Tonic also for real Gin
Tonic Geschmack am Popcorn wie soll das
Schmecken Butter Karamell erstmal geil
wacholder ist ja das was Gin ausmacht
und Limette wahrscheinlich um das Chinin
die Säure vom Tonic abzubilden woW ist
es den preiswert wir finden es heraus
wir finden es heraus nach einer kurzen
wer runterbrechen bei blockcha wenn man
eine Nase davon nimmt dann riecht es
wirklich
nach Gin Tonic guck mal rein die sind
wirklich alle samt sehr sehr schön
gleichmäßig bedeckt hat das gerade wie
so eine bazooker so wenn wir uns treffen
kennst du jemals noch normales Popcorn
in Kinos bestellen ich finde es wirklich
krass wie die es geschafft haben Gin
Tonic abzubilden in popcornform sowas
abheben will wo auch die Drinks dann 10
15 € Kosten da sehe ich das bei einem
fernseherabend sehe ich das irgendwie
nicht Preis-Leistung gebe ich dem ganzen
7,5 von zehn von zehn Preis Leistungen
wird schwer heute bin ich ganz ehrlich
weil das muss halt einfach dann mich
komplett umhauen geschmacklich diese
Geschmacksrichtung Gin Tonic ist eine 9
von 10 wenn man Gin Tonic Geschmack
liebt für mich persönlich geschmacklich
eher so eine sieben von zehn aber das
ist schon echt gut gemacht kommen wir
jetzt unsere Hauptspeise des Menüs
Spaghetti Carbonara das Wasser denn wir
machen passt da bin sehr gespannt ob das
was taugt weil gute fertig passt da gibt
es noch nicht 500 Gramm Nudeln haben wir
hier drin plus 60 g gewürzt Zubereitung
denn das hier jetzt wirklich eine krasse
Carbonara ist mit einer schönen Creme
und so dann ist das den preiswert weil
sonst brauchst du dann schade du
brauchst Eier du musst verschiedene
Sorten Käse ver wenn es das hier alles
kann habe ich gerne die 8 Euro dies
kostet das ist die Gewürz Zubereitung
und hier drin haben wir die Nudeln und
jetzt bin ich nämlich gespannt was haben
die für Nudeln drin nein Alter bei 8
Euro ich hätte gewettet dass das
irgendwie so Spaghetti albbron so sind
ne diese Frauen teuren Spaghetti weil da
kostet eine Packung wenn du sie einfach
kaufst beim Großhandel 5 € so dann
verstehe ich auch ach so aber ich gucke
mal nach wie viel diese Pasta hier
kostet
99 Cent brauchen Sie nicht
180 ml kochendes Wasser ist einfach
getrocknet ist voll Ei drin also einfach
Eier die dehydriert wurden und keine
Ahnung ich muss auch eine Menge Soße
ergeben ne wenn das für 500 g Nudeln ist
und vorne zwei bis drei Esslöffel machen
nach Gefühl eins zwei drei Esslöffel und
gucken was jetzt passiert dann steht
jetzt eine schöne Creme dann wäre ich
auf jeden Fall froh es ist flüssiger
total flüssig
die machen schon viel falsch ne Topf
verwenden
[Musik]
nein
8 Minuten sind vorbei das heißt wir
teilen die Nudeln jetzt so wie uns
gehießen wurde auf drei bis vier
Portionen wir machen einfach mal drei
Portionen also bleibt halt auch nach
acht Minuten noch ziemlich flüssig nee
ging es jetzt alle Male dieser Teller
Nudeln kostet runtergerechnet 2,65 € was
preislich auf jeden Fall okay ist
andererseits hätte man sich irgendwie
eine fertige karbonara Soße gekauft und
die 1 € Nudeln dazu einmal
wahrscheinlich bei einem geringeren
Preis rausgekommen ich schieb alle
Vorteile beiseite und probiere diese
Pasta
[Musik]
sie macht mich traurig ist eine
Carbonara die einen traurig macht da
fehlt wie viel hat das mit Carbonara zu
tun für mich überhaupt gar nicht also
ich würde fast so weit gehen dass jede
fertig so ist wahrscheinlich besser ist
halt aber auch wieder die Frage für wen
das ist ne niemanden das ist einfach nur
achtung Achtung also Geschmack zwei von
zehn Preis Leistung 1 von 10 sorry aber
also bin normalerweise nicht so aber das
ist wirklich
das ist ein bisschen enttäuschend finde
ich gehen wir zur nächsten Produkt
jeweils 8 Euro kriegen wir
Rinderrouladen und zitronenrisotto
vielleicht nicht die klassischste
Kombination aber wir machen das
gemeinsam denn das hier ist nur eine
Beilage das alles brauchen wir nämlich
noch zusätzlich nehmen wir die
Rinderroulade mitsamt Inhalt mal hinein
was natürlich super cool ist dass wir
das ganze hier angerichtet ist ne also
wir haben quasi von Hand wahrscheinlich
Geschichte die einzelnen Zutaten alles
einmal raus haben wir es dann auch
darauf geben jetzt 100 ml was denkt das
ganze ist dass die gefriergetrockneten
Zutaten sich wieder so ein bisschen
hydrieren können und dann halt nicht
gleich verbrennen wenn wir sind im Kopf
haben right Leute ein bisschen Butter in
unseren Topf darin schwitzen wir gleich
eine Schalotte an die wir dazu gekauft
haben und ansonsten kann ich gerade
gefragt was kriege ich dadurch dass ich
8 € Bezahlen im Prinzip weglassen ja gut
und ich muss keine Petersilie schneiden
keine Zwiebelschneiden keine
zitronenzeste reiben aber so in den 10
Minuten dieses auch selber schneiden 1/4
Teelöffel Kurkuma kommt jetzt dazu diese
schöne gelbe Farbe und jetzt löschen wir
das ganze mit 200 ml Weißwein ab
aber so richtig jetzt noch nicht so
super lecker da muss man sagen die
Roulade hingehen
jetzt schütten wir unsere Brühe auf
nicht alles auf einmal sondern immer
wieder so steht es auf der Packung
okay Leute das Risotto ist soweit
gekocht es sieht nicht schlecht aus das
Ding ist ich würde zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt als safe noch mal ordentlich
Butter und Parmesan dazu machen damit es
diese schlotzigkeit bekommt die machen
es halt aber strickt nach
zubereitungsangabe und da steht's nicht
drauf sondern dass wir es mit ein zwei
Teelöffeln Zitronensaft Reis und Pfeffer
abschmecken Salz Pfeffer habe ich schon
drin Zitronensaft jetzt auch das heißt
wir servieren die Roulade und das
Risotto und sehen uns gleich am Tisch
kommen wir zur letzten Mahlzeit des
Tages einmal das Zitronen
petersilienrisotto und die Rouladen die
Rouladen riechen ziemlich gut das
einzige was mich so ein bisschen
irritiert ist wie stark diese
Flüssigkeit aus unserem gelehrt ist
Risotto das sieht irgendwie schon ein
bisschen fertig aus ne also durch die
Farbe der Petersilie und so vor allem
wir haben es wirklich dafür dass es
jetzt ohne Butter und Parmesan am Ende
ist ganz schwarze hinbekommen es sollte
auf jeden Fall gut sein wenn wir nicht
nur viel Geld sondern auch viel Zeit
investieren
[Musik]
fühlst du den knack so ein bisschen
das Risotto hat noch bis es ist voll
bitter auch ja meine ich ja da sind ja
Zitronenschalen drin vielleicht war das
weiße an den Zitronenschalen auch mit
dabei was zu bitter ist gefällt mir
überhaupt nicht es schmeckt einfach
nicht lecker es gefällt mir wirklich
überhaupt nicht also es ist richtig
bitter also mit dem Aufwand da hätte man
auch ein normales Risotto machen können
löst ähnliche Gefühle in mir aus wie die
Spaghetti davor probieren wir erstmal
die Roulade allergieber ohne Witz das
lässt sich ohne Messer so perfekt
aufteilen das ist vielversprechend
bisschen ausblenden wie das gerade
aussah und probieren kann man wirklich
abseits der Säure die da drin ist
schmeckt das über Oma also wirklich die
ist richtig schön zart und wirklich
alles in allem bedeuten besser als
gedacht es hat sich komplett gewendet
und 180 Grad ich dachte die Rouladen war
wirklich nicht essen und das Risotto war
richtig gut aus Roulade Geschmack sieben
von zehn Eis Leistung lokine acht von
zehn weil Rouladen zu machen ist ein
verdammter pennen die es hier mhm
geschmacklich ist das hier eine zwei von
zehn es ist wirklich nicht gut zu sauer
es ist einfach nicht das Risotto was es
sein könnte wenn man es nicht benutzt
Preis-Leistung man spart sich ein
bisschen zu schnibbeln und dadurch hat
man es ein bisschen convenient hatte
dieses coole wegglas noch dazu drei von
zehn aber ihr merkt Leute teuer ist
nicht gleich gut ich glaube mit weniger
Geld oder auch mit günstigeren Produkten
hätten wir heute teilweise wirklich
bessere Produkte gehabt gut dass also
ich da bin um sie für euch zu testen
schreibt mal in die Kommentare wenn ihr
ein paar zwei davon haben wollt wir
sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder bis
dahin macht's gut und ciao